they're co-creators and stars up shits
Creek Eugene and Dan levy step in as
guest hosts on Ellen today this is very
fun and shockingly were related this is
a crazy coincidence we just happen to be
guest hosting the same week that our
show shits Creek is back for its sixth
and final year the levees welcomed
co-star Annie Murphy who they pranked
during her first time on the show and
Catherine O'Hara
the rose family played say what and as
you can assume hilarity ensued according
to myth
darling dan actually taught eugene about
the birds and the bees when you're about
to have a bath about the birds of the
bees
when the mouse has a bath this Tuesday
he needs to use the mouth East ma with
mouth with mouth there's a small door
with a mouthpiece tell me what you dr.
yurt with a small mouthpiece you can
have a very good Christmas Catherine
also shared the story of the very first
time she met her lifelong friend Eugene
I was in high school yes I was I but I
was there for 12 years I was in high
school and you were in Godspell and my
brother was dating Gilda Radner god
bless her and she got Robin Duke and me
tickets to Godspell and we got to hang
out with you the cast afterwards at the
restaurant after it was the most
thrilling thing for Robin Duke and me
and that's where I first met you and
then you allowed me to be cast alongside
you when Gil the left second city
theater and I got to be in the theater
with you the sixth and final season of
shits Creek premiered earlier this week
Rose Weston chatted with stars Annie
Murphy and Noah Reed who said that Dan
has always known how the series will end
and he actually loved keeping the season
so did you know going into season six
actually where season 6 was going no Dan
took great joy in being like I know
every one of those anyone right I mean
for a very weepy last few table reads
that describes life I can imagine
because you know we're winding down and
everyone's just like going through it
for the first time and trying to hold
back it's such a good season and we're
lucky because Dano was knew that we were
doing six right so every storyline is
tied up so nicely
there's there are so many good laughs
but there are so many like punches to
the heart at the same time so at the end
does everybody get a happy ending
[Music]
it looks pretty good
and carlos bustamante recently caught up
with eugene for a special one-on-one and
when talking about working with his son
Eugene became visibly emotional so Dan
recently revealed the gift that you gave
to him on the final day of shooting this
framed photograph my dad actually gave
me this little framed photo on the last
day of shooting our show was a say on
that
it says Daniel it was an honor being
your partner son dad exhale oh no I
don't want to cry for you folks but I
just might it was actually a photograph
that was taken by our hair stylist on
the show Anya Soros she took this pic of
the two of us actually from from behind
sitting in our directors or our chairs
Johnny Rose and David Rose chairs and I
happen to have my hand on his shoulder
as we were watching something on the
monitor I thought it was an appropriate
picture to give him on as a parting gift
and I think well and now I've got to get
through this without choking up but it
was I think I said it was it was an
honor being your partner son so what do
you think of Eugene and Dan's
guest-hosting abilities how do you think
the series will end what has been your
favorite moment from the entire series
mine Patrick's coming out in season 5 it
was incredibly powerful to to read and
receive so many messages from people who
just felt so seen and represented in
that moment I know it's something that
Dan and all of our writers took great
care to construct it was quite a special
storyline and and those scenes were
incredibly special to shoot shits Creek
is nominated at the upcoming GLAAD Media
Awards for Outstanding Comedy Series and
it is so well deserved don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube
[Music]